you you've written about the importance
of language in intelligent civilizations
um
how difficult is the problem to bridge
the gap between aliens and humans
yeah in terms of language so we're not
lost in translation yeah i mean there's
different takes on that depending on how
biologically similar they are
to us you know i mean there's a school
of thought that says
basically
uh
advanced life has to be carbon based
for just reasons of chemistry so right
away if you impose that limitation then
you're you're kind of assuming a uh
something that's starting to be
biologically similar to us
so if they're about as big as we are and
uh you know they um they they kind of
move around in in space you know a
physical body the way we do then then
there's probably a way to to solve that
communication problem
uh if they're you know like beings of
pure energy from star trek or something
like that then
it's a different story well i love
thinking about that kind of stuff too i
mean this
you know
consciousness itself may be it may be
alien i mean it could be
like you said beings of pure energy
um
i i think i think of life
as just complex systems and the kind of
forms those complex systems can take
seems to be much larger than the
particular biological systems we see
here on earth
you